[موسيقى]
اهلا بكل مشاهدي فرنسا بضيوف برنامج
النقاش الذين تشاهدونهم على الشاشه هم
بالطبع ينتظرونا
ينتظرون اسئلتكم
وتعليقاتكم على على صفحتي صفحه البرنامج
على فيسبوك او على صفحه البرنامج على
تويتر
للمره الرابعه في تاريخ يتاهل المنتخب
الفرنسي الى نهائي كاس العالم يواجه هذه
المره الارجنتين لاحد المقبله على حساب
المنتخب المغربي الذي قبل البلاء الحسن
وقدم اداء مميزا يؤكد جدارته بان يكون اول
فريق افريقي وعربي يصل الى هذه المرحله
وفرنسا تطمع الى الحصول على لقب ثالث كي
تنتهي بما فعلته البرازيل وايطاليا سنتحدث
عن اداء الفريقين الفرنسي والمغربي عن
الاستعدادات للنهائي وعم تميز به
المونديال هذه المره وطبعا عندما يتعلق
الامر في نقاش رياضي لسنا في حاجه الى
اسئله
وسعيد بان يكون معي في الاستديو محمد
وهو مدرب وهو محلل رياضي سعيد بان يكون
معي من الرباط عادل العلوي وهو صحفي رياضي
سعيد دائما بان يكون معي من تونس العاصمه
وفي الموعد الصعيدي
عالمي رياضي وصحفي سابق في كنال بليس اهلا
وسهلا بكم
قبل ان نبدا نستمع الى ما قاله الرئيس
الفرنسي
بعد المباراه
اريد ان يستمتع الفرنسيون بهذه السعاده
البسيطه كونوا سعداء ثم اريد ان اقول
للمغاربه
في كاس العالم
وهذا اليوم عبرتم على حسن استعدادكم من
جديدنا يجب ان نستمتع بهذه السعاده ثم
بدايه من هذا المساء يجب ان السعاده
نستمع لما قاله عدد من المشجعين للفريق
المغربي
المنتخب
اكثر من رائع مباشره
صحيح مرحله ما بعد المباراه مختلفه بعض
الشيء عن مرحله ما قبل المباراه على اساس
ان اغلبيه المشجعين همم الذين جاءوا من
المغرب او من دول اوروبيه وذكاء الكثير من
المغربيين الذين جاءوا من دول اوروبيه
التقينا بهم في الايام الاخيره اغلبيتهم
عادوا بالطبع الى بلادهم الى الدول التي
يعيشون فيها واا هناك عدد اقل بالطبع همم
هنا لمتابعه المباراه على المرتبه الثالثه
يوم السبت المقبل في مواجهه كرواتيا في
المقابل هناك العديد من المشجعين ال-
الارجنتينيين وهم حقيقه منذ بدايه
المونديال المشجعون الارجنتينون هم الاكثر
عددا والذين لهم همم دائما في سوق واقف
حيث نرى صباح حتى المساء حتى الليل ساعات
متاخره من الليل يوميا همم مشجعين هناك
الارجنتينيون ومشجعين المنتخب الارجنتيني
لان هناك ظاهره استدعيه هنا نموذج بدايه
المونديال عدد مشجعين المنتخب الارجنتيني
من غير الارجنتينيين الذين نراهم هنا
دائما بشكل خاص القادمين من السعوديه همم
نعرب ان في المملكه العربيه السعوديه هناك
عشق لكره القدم جنوب امريكيه للارجنتين
وللبرازيل على طريقه الكلاسيكو على طريقه
ريال برشلونه هناك من يحب الارجنتين هناك
من يحب البرازيل وكل من يحب الارجنتين
ياتي دائما ربما
ليوم او ليومين لمتابعه مباراه يعودون
بلدهم ويعودون من جديد الى هنا لمتابعه
لمباراه المنتخب
الارجنتيني ورقم 10 واسم ميسي
شكرا
حول المنتخب
ما هي الامور التي لم تكن مت حتى
يتمكن ال المنتخب المغربي من التسجيل
بالامس ولو ان الفرص كانت عديده
مساء الخير بدايه اليك استاذ توفيق مساء
الخير لكل الضيوف وايضا لكل المشاهدين عبر
اا قناه
اااه صحيح ان المنتخب الوطني المغربي
بالامس همم انهزم بهدف دون مقابل
انهزم امام ابطال العالم ولما نقول ابطال
العالم فريق يملك الثقافه والاسلحه في مثل
هذه المناسبات وبالتالي هي التي كانت
حاسمه في تحديدها
الفائز بالامس بالامس همم كان المنتخب
الوطني المغربي
بمنظومته الدفاعيه برجاله المحاربين وايضا
بقائده
في الموعد ولكن كانت امور ربما حاله دون
ال ال يعني
بنفس المظهر الذي ظهر به امام اسبانيا
والبرتغال
وبالنظر اولا الى مجموعه من الاعطاب التي
لحقت العناصر المغربيه بالنظر ايضا الى
الاجهاد والتعب الذي ايضا نال المنظومه
المغربيه ككل بالنظر الى المجهود الذي
بدلوه في مبارتي اسبانيا والبرتغال ناهيك
ايضا على ان همم يعني التكتيك الخاص
بالمبارك كان يختلف عن التكتيك الخاص به
بالمباريات السابقتين فرنسا طبقت نفس
التكتيك الذي كان قد طبقه المغرب في
المباراه السابقه وبالتالي كانت هي
السباقه الى كسب اللقاء والى كسب المفاتيح
اللعب خاصه لما كان الهدف الاول الذي جاء
في دقيقه المبكره وبالتالي
اللاعب لم يكن رد فعل المنتخب كما كان في
همم المباريات السابقه طيب مراد صغير اريد
رايك انت الذي تتابع كره القدم منذ فتره
طويله الخطه الجديده شو يعني رغم نقص
اللاعبين وانت تعلم من هناك من اصيب حتى
قبل المباراه هناك من اصيب يعني اصيب
اصيبوا هناك حتى من مرض وحاله حتى مرض ومع
ذلك نجح خاصه في عمليه تغيير اللاعبين
هو الانتصار دائما جميل يعني ولما ينتصر
فريق صعب ان نقده لكن هذا لا يمنع انه
البارحه وان كانت على العموم فرنسا يستحق
الانتصار فانا لم تعطي صوره الفريق
الموسيتر الفريق الذي يفرض اسلوب لعبه
مره اخرى وان هو همم على هذا المستوى
بتدقيققا قوتي في قدرته على التاقلم مع
المنافسه طبعا كنا ننتظر ان فرنسا وهي
بطله العالم وهي الفريق الذي يملك اكثر
نجوم ان يكون خلي يقول في همم طريقه
التفكير مختلفه في مقابله المغرب لكن في
الاخير قبل السيطره المغربيه وفاز بطريقه
فيها طبعا همم يعني كل الخصوصيات للفريق
الكبير يعني الخبره القدره على امتصاص
الضغط دون الانهيار تماما هنا ثم يخص
المباراه
كل المسيره الفرنسيه في كاس العالم
هي بصراحه مسيره يعني لي دي دي دي دي
الشندور كبير جدا فيها لان ما حصل فريق
الفرنسي من ايسابيد قبل الدوره في بدايه
الدوره وفي مباراه النصف النهائي همم لو
كان اي فريق اخر لا انهي كماما ولا فقد
السيطره ولا لم لم يصل لم ي- ال- يضرني لا
موجب ان نذكر ايه سبب كريم بنزيما بول
بوغبا نقولو كونتي
لوكاس في اول الدوره همم
مدافع عن باريس سان جيرمان كذلك كان لاعبا
اساسيا كونكو وهو احسن هداف البوندسليجا
كان يمكن ان يكون يعني لاعب احتياطي متميز
اضف الى هذا همم تقريبا ابرز لاعبين في
مباراتين الاخيرتين يعني رابيو وقوفا
ميكانو بالرغم من هنا دي دي
نجح في ان يكون فريقا قادرا على الفوز وهو
الان في كره القدم في الاخر ممكن ان تكون
لدينا حول جمالي يتلعب حول البعد الفورجوي
من عدمه لكن ماذا سيذكر التاريخ يا توفيق
سيذكره عند فرنسا حققت انجيزنت تاريخيا
بوصولها للدور النهائي اربع سنوات بعد دور
نهائي 2018 طيب ضربه جزائم ليس ضربه جزاء
مراد
هي هي شوف الروايتين تستويين ليش لانه هي
ال- ال- الكوره ما كانتش ميشيه بالتدقيق
نحو اللاعب لم يكن زاهبا نحو همم اللاعب
الفرنسي يعني لا كان ذلك نحو الكره لم يكن
دائما
المغربي وبالتالي في تلك السرعه يعني
الحكم لم يرى ضربه جزاء طبعا تدخل الفار
في هيتيه الدوره في كل مره عموما كان مع
المنتخب الفرنساوي لم يضر بمصالح المنتخب
الفرنسي ههه طيب تاريخك على ما قراتها
تمام لا يمكن ان تقول ما تريد
[موسيقى]
في الاول يكون
المنتخب المغربي
ممتازه الى حد بعيد
بامكانيات اللي عنده الامكانيات
هائله
وبشخصيه المدرب شخصيا ان شاء الله
واحنا
ثانيا نقدر نقول بالعاميه
هذا هو اهم اما عن المباراه لو تسمح همم
عندي سؤال للاخ عادل
انا حبيت نعرف ماذا دار بين المدرب وبين
سايس وبين
اللاعب تاني الذي خرج ااا لاعب
المزراوي هل اللاعبان نعم هل اللاعبان
قالوا وكانوا في مستوى الحدث وان يقول
الحقيقه
للمدرب انهم كانوا كما يقولوا احنا واجدين
100% ام انهم ارادوا اللعب وخرجوا
كي تاثير هنا في همم تاثير في في خطه في
خطه المدرب وكان لو سمحت تكون واحد
الانسان مش قادر يلعب 100 بالمئه ما يلعبش
هذا ما فعله
في المق
ابل
لمركز
واحترمه
واحترمك كثير همم المغرب لذا فاز
عندما نرى ان همم
قال وسرح ان الفريق المغربي فريق كبير
بامكانيات كبيره بمشروع لاعب بخطه لم يكن
مخطئ ولكن الفعالي كانت من ناحيه من ناحيه
فرنسا ولكن
ربما ربما من لاعبين في
المستوى هذا المستوى كامل يحبو
ولكن
الفريق في في موقع حرج اظن ان من الانسب
ومن الحق ان يكون اللاعبين في في حقيقه
بدنيه
هو هو ربما انه الاشياء او ما تم او ما تم
تداوله ما بين اللاعبين وايضا المدرب ربما
تبقى شيء ربما خصوصي هدف البدايه لان
وعلاش لان مدرب الوريد العراقي استثمر في
قلوب اللاعبين في البدايه واستطاع ان يوحد
قلوب اللاعبين والوحده ايضا النجوميه
اللاعبين في المجموعه معنى ذلك انه لما
مباراه
المنتخب المغربي ضد المنتخب البلجيكي ولما
شعر بونو بدوران قد في مرحله الاحماء
قالها صراحه تم التغييره هنا كانت اراده
اللاعب اقوى من اراده المدرب ولو ان
المدرب اصر على بقاء بونو
اسرع ايضا على الخروج وايضا على التغيير
هنا في هذه الحاله لما تيجي يسال المدرب
وتيقول لها لانه فعلا هل لديك القدره وهل
لديك ايضا الرغبه في مواصله في اللعب
والانسان راح السيسي ده عميد فريق ولاعب
اكبر لاعب سنا واكثر لاعب تجربه اكثر لاعب
لاعب مع المنتخب الوطني المغربي مع ان ذلك
انه لن يغامر
يعني باصابته وبعطه من اجل مواصله اللاعب
فبدون شكله لانه كان جاهزا في البدايه
ولكن لما او اسلوب اللعب كان هذه جدا
وايضا ال- ال- ال- الدفاع على من اجل لاعب
اخر كان اكثر سرعه خاصه انه ال- ال- ال-
الركنه دياله والجر دياله وايضا العمليات
الفرضيه دياله صعبه جدا فبالتالي لم
يستطيع مقاومه المد الهجومي للاعب بابي
وايضا للاعبين الاخير خاصه
الى همم تغيير صحيح انه ربما اخطا اللاعب
وليس المدرب اخطا اللاعب في التقدير وفي
ضروره المشاركه ولكن لا يمكن يعني ان لوما
لا اللاعب ولا المدرب بيغذي النظر عن
الاشياء التي
بالمباراه مسبقه بطبيعه الحال ولاحظنا ما
نايف اكرد نايف اكرد كان يعني في في ال ال
11 اللاعبين الاساسيين وخرجت خرج اسمهما
اللاعبين الاولين ولكن في الاحماء تم
تغيير لانه شعر بانه لن يستطيع مسيرته
ايقاع اللاعب طيب وديع تريد تفضل توفيق
توفيق
نعم نعم اذا سمحت توفيق بالنسبه لهذا
الموضوع انا همم اطرح سؤال ايضا يعني
تحديدا هل غير وليد الركراكي اسلوب اللعب
تحديدا همم من اجل دعم قائده رومانسيه في
خط الدفاع يعني عندما يقدر همم طبعا يعلم
وان همم قرر همم اللاعب في بدايه اللقاء
كان يعلم المدرب انه ليس بيئه في المئه من
قدراته فهل لهذا سبب وضع مدافع اضافي الى
جانبه وعندكروجه ادخل ليس مدافع ما كان ان
لاعب وسط وعاد الى طريقه اللاعب همم
السابقه التي كانت ناجحه في المباريات
السابقه كرواتيا بلجيكا اسبانيا
وكذلك البرتغال بطريقه واحد اربعه واحد
همم هذه هذا هو الاسلوب الذي كان بالنسبه
للمنتخب المغربي في المباراه السابقه
والذي عاد اليه وليد
من مباراه فرنسا بعد خروج قائده قبل ذلك
كان اعتمد اسلوب مختلف تماما همم مع
مدافعين اربعه في الوسط وواحد ربما ممكن
ان نقول 5 4 1 يعني من اجل التبسيط الامور
هل وضع مدافع اضافي له دعم همم سيس تحديدا
وتمامن ايضا من الناحيه اليسرى يعني كنا
شاهدنا في المباراه السابقه للمنتخب
المغربي عطيه الله اللاعب الشاب المبتدا
يعني في هذا المستوى الذي كان استثنائيه
هو الذي كان اهدا الهدف للنصيري ورا انه
ايضا عندما دخل في شوط الثاني امس كان
ممتازا افضل بكثير من الميراوي ربما ربما
هناك تساؤلات طبعا
في عدد كبير من المنتخبات وايضا على مستوى
الانديه هذه المسائل همم في نهايه الاسبوع
دائما في البطولات المحليه همم لاعبون
احيانا
يشددوا على انهم يريدون اللاعب برغم من
انهم لا يعرفون انهم لا يستطيعون تقديم كل
ما لديهم بيئه في المئه واحيانا دائما
هناك احيانا تحصل هذه
سوء تفاهم اذا جاز تعبير بين اللاعب او
اللاعبين والجهاز الفني مراد صغير انت
تعرف اسرار المدربين تفضل يمكن ان ترد على
وديع
طبعا لما انهزم الفريق المغربي همم يمكن
بالنقد فتح على مسرح وليد
يعني لو انه نعمق الجراح بعض
[موسيقى]
في اخر مباراه المغرب واسبانيا يعني كان
من الواضح انه حتى مباراه البرتغال لم يكن
100% وان كان يعني مردوده ممتاز
ممكن الفرق
[موسيقى]
جديد
عنده عنده مشاكل صحيه على العموم بسيطه
ليست مشاكل
في بدايه الدوره لانه اعتبر انه لا يريد
اي لاعب موجود في القائمه مش على الميدان
اذا لم يكن بدنيا جاهز 100% طبعا بالنسبه
للفريق المغربي قال المعادله تختلف نوعا
ماء لانه الفريق ليس له او المدرب ليس له
نفس الحلول او امكانيه التعويل علاء زائد
بشري مثلا لذلك المتوفر
مراد حبيت نتدخل همم اخي ما رايك في همم
في مضرب بانون انا انا اظن اظن ان الحل
كان في بدر بانون يدخل يعز الدفاع في
الوسط لان
حكيمي عنده نزهه هجوميه
الله اعلم انا اقول لست في مكان راج راجي
ولكن اقول ان باضرب بانون ربما كان يكون
الحل
طب شوف هو الرقراق الشيء الواضح بالنسبه
لي هو انه عنده ما يسمى رشيد
دفاع رقم واحد رقم اثنين رقم ثلاثه هو
عنده قيمه عنده همم ثقه عميقه ثقه يدي
يبدولي انه ثقته في بدر بنون اقل نوعا ثم
انه تغيير الخطه فيه وعليه لكن مفهومه
بصراحه ملوش معلش لان انت اخذتك نشحد
اذكره وبلجيكا واسبانيا والبرتغال تقريبا
لعبته بنفس الخطه التكتيكيه وصلت الناس في
نهائي عندك امامك لاعب عالمي مثلا
حسيت اشرف حكيمي مش 100 100
تقلق شويه من
الرسم التكتيكي الموجود لكن هنا طبعا بعد
الهزيمه كما يقولوا ال ال الانتصار له بيع
عددين ولا هزيمه يتيمه يعني احنا الكل مش
نقوله الهزيمه هي هزيمه رجراجي انا بصراحه
لا اريد ان اعمق هذا هذا النقاش في المغرب
نحكم عليه على طول كاس العالم والحسيله
ايجابيه جدا والبارح يعني اي فريق اي فريق
في العالم كان ممكن ان ينهزم ضد فرنسا
مهما كانت الاختيارات حقيقي
سي مراد
وهو يعرف اكثر مني لانه يعني نسبه نجاح
الخطه ونجاح الفريق هي اني همم نسبه كبيره
منها تاتي من الاخت البشريه
والاختيارات البشريه بطبيعه الحال همم
يعني اما تكون همم
تصيب او ان تخطئ صحيح ان الرجراجي اصاب في
خمس او ست مباريات ولم يصب في مباراه
فرنسا ممكن ولكن المراد الذي كان يعني
يريده وليد الركراكي هو وضع خطه خمسه
اربعه واحد فيما يخص
التكتيك ال ال يعني المنهج على مستوى
المباراه فرنسا
وبالتالي وضع اللاعب همم يعني همم
الرومانسيس العميد في في يعني في في صف
الاخير او في صفين مريح بالنظر الى ان
الضغط سيتحمله كل من الياميق ويتحمله ايضا
امرابط ويتحمل ايضا الاحي ال ال الشيء
الذي وقع هو انه لم يتحمل الضغط وتلقى
وهدف في المبكر اربك الحسابات كلها هذا هو
الشيء اللي ربما يعني اثار بعض ال ال يعني
الحساسيه على مستوى يعني اللعب المنظومه
التقنيه لوليد الركراكي الذي كانت ناجحه
100% ولكن يعني كبت في هذه المباراه
واعتقدها انه كما ذكر سيد مراد كان ولو
يعني ممكن ان ندخل اللاعبين 26 لم نكن ان
نستطيع
المد الهجومي
هذا اللاعب الذي السريع في العالم واللاعب
الذي يمكن ان يهز الشباب في اي لحظه
الان ما وقع وقع 30 يمكن يقولوا له لانه
المنتخب الفرنسي
ولو انه سجل اهداف
التي كانت عند المنتخب المغربي في الجوله
الثانيه كانت جيده جدا بل اكثر من ذلك لو
استغلت السغلت الفرص التي فتحت المستويات
لا كان قد تجد على الاقل هدفا ولقد ولكان
لقد اربك المنظومه التقنيه للمنتخب
الفرنسي باش نكون واضحين فرنسا يعني لم
يعني لم تفز وهي مستريحه ولكن فازت وتعددت
وضل الشك الى اخر دقيقتين من المباراه
ناهيك عن ضربه جزاء الذي يمكن ان نقول انه
ضربه جزاء اذا سرقت للمنتخب الوطني
المغربي يعني كان معروف امور بوفال دخل
الى منطقه الجزاء وكان يعني كانت هناك
عرقله واضحه سواء الكلام متجا الى المرمى
المعروف في قوانين التحكيم الذي عقل في
منطقه الجزاء ضربه جزاء
الحكم لم يستشر حتى الباص وان كان قد
استشاره الله اعلم
بقيت مش متعارف فيما يخص هذا المباراه
ضربه جزاء واليوم الجامعه الملكيه لكره
القدم قدمت احتجاجا رسميا
اللجنه التحكيم بالفيفا من اجل النظر في
موضوع الضربه الجزاء التي حرم بناء
المنتخب الوطني المغربي ويمكن القلوب ضربه
جزاء ولكن واحده كانت واضحه جدا للاعب بو
فا لحتى نوضح الامور اما ما وصلنا اليه
على مستوى المنتخب المغربي فيمكن اعتباره
ان انجازا تاريخيا بالاعجاز وربما انه
الان لو اراد منتخب افريقيا او عربيا ان
يتجاوز الثقافه ما وصل اليه المنتخب
المغربي فعله ان يتاهل الى المباراه
النهائيه عادل همم
[موسيقى]
لو تسمح همم
توفيق انتقل الكلام اللي قاده عادل قال
وعد العلوي من الرباط ونشاتره تقريبا ميه
ميه هو الاسكيل الاشكال يعني هو احيانا في
مباريات مهمه اختيارات المدرب اكيد مهمه
لكن احيانا هناك لاعبين تعامل عليهم ولا
تجدهم يوم المباراه فهل المغرب لعبت دون
قلب هجوم الرقم الموجع بالنسبه للمغرب هو
النيسري اللي يمثل سكور مباراه كامله يعني
بس ثلاثه مرات فقدت الكره في حين انه كان
عنصر متميز في مباريات الاخرى بالتالي فان
الفريق بالشيخلق اختر مالقاش ذلك اللعب
الموجود في ال 20 متر الاخيره الذي يعطيه
العمق ما نحبش نستعمل تلك الجمله ولكن
مثال استعملها مره اخيره يكفي للمغرب فخرا
انه فرنسا تقريبا في المباراه المغرب كانت
في اسوء صوره منذ بدايه كاس العالم لا
اعتبار مبارات تونس
فرنسا كانت مترشحه ولعب الفريق من ال- من
الاحتياطيين لكن بالاساسيين فرنسا امبارح
كانت اقل مباراه اقنعت فيها واقل مباراه
سيطر فيها عدل هل تسمعونا لا يسمعون هذه
سيعود الصوت بعد قليل
توجه الى الاخ مراد
ما يقدرناش ننومه
ما شاء الله ده ما في وسعه ان يؤدي
بالمجموعه
بالمجموعه بالمشروع بطريقه بالاستراتيجيه
الفريق المغربي كان في في في في كان في في
الحدث نقولها
بالفم المليان اما عن الاختيارات
اظن ان همم
هناك ربما ربما اختيارات كانت تكون احسن
بالمقابل فريق الفرنسي فريق الفرنسي كان
واقعي الى حد بعيد اما عن عن
خطه خطه المنتخب المغربي
في التحول من الدفاع الى الهجوم شفنا في
المقابلات الفارطه ان الفريق المغربي كان
يمشي يمشي
اقولها بصراحه
انها فازت على الفريق المغربي
وصل الى الى وصل الى النهائي نصف النهائي
اول فريق عربي
وافريقي وموس وفريق مسلم يصل الى هذه
الدرجه وعلى الفرق الاخرى همم الافريقيه
والعربيه والاسلاميه ان تفعل ماذا فعل
المغرب حقيقه المغرب وصلاه الى تربه سوف
نرى ذلك همم مراد ذلك يوم السبت بالنسبه
للمباراه معكرواتيا هل تعتقد ان في نوع من
الارياحيه لانك تلعب عن المرتبه الثالثه
عالميه هل يمكن للمنتخب المغربي ان يخرج
في صورته الحقيقيه دون خوف امام الفريق
الكرواتي الذي هو الاخر قبل البلاء الحسن
ولكنه طبعا فشلت في المباراه الاخيره
المباراه الترتيبيه توفيق في كل دورات كاس
العالم
للمعايير هي احسن ومش احسن لانه خلي نعطي
صوره
للمتفرجين ساعه ممكن المهم ان نقول انه
فما عدد كبير من الملحدين والمدربين
يطالبون بالغاء هذه المباراه هذه المباراه
هذه التقاليد يعني عندها علاقه بالحركه
الاولمبيه لانه صاحب المرتبه الثالثه
يتحسر على الميداليه البرونزيه وما لا
معنى له يعني اليوم في 2000 سنه و20 في
قاولين كاس امم افريقيا بطوله امم اوروبا
مثلا ليس هناك فيها مباراه ترتيب
لادرينالين تحت
سقطت انهارت الادرينالين انهار ذلك الضغط
الايجابي او تلك الطاقه التي تدفع
اللاعبين المغاربه والكروات في نفس في نفس
الخانه لننسى انه لاعبين المغاربه
والكروات موجودين في طرابلس مغلق محرومين
من صديقاتهم وزوجاتهم وابنائهم وابائهم
وامهم منذ حوالي شهر وهو طبعا همم يؤرقوا
احيانا
اللاعبين وتصبح لهم نيه واحده وهي العوده
الى الديار او العوده الى همم
لا يبدوني ان ياتي المقابله سيلعبها
لاعبين دي فعلا كبير الا من لم ياخذ
المباريات كاس العالم او من كان عنصر
احتياطيا وهي فرصه البروز والظهور بالنسبه
الي نعرفه همم
ورئيسي همم يعني همم يحبوا يكملوا كاس
العالم بانتسار
بيحبوا كذلك يديهم للجمهور المغربي
والعربي والافريقي وهما جارا انتصار اخير
ولكن تقعد تشوفوا المقابل هذه ترجم تكون
فيها الكثير من المفاجاه ولا يمكن ليست
مباراه عاديه هي مباراه من دون ضغوطات
ولكن كذلك ليست مباراه وديه هي بين في في
منطقه رماديه تقريبا
لا انا فقط غير انا فقط بفتح قوس سيموراد
يعني قال انه
يكون نازل وبالتالي يعني هذا المباراه
يمكن على المستوى يعني على مستوى كاس
العالم يعني ما عندها معنى ولكن اعتقد ان
ان معناها كبير اولا على مستوى الترتيب
الفيفا
لانه منتخب بلجيكي لما كان في المركز
الثالث حفظه على مركز الثالث حافظ على
ترتيب
طويله معنى ذلك ان المنتخب
فوزيه
المنتخب البلجيكي بهذا بهذا الترتيب الاول
ما هي قيمته في الاخر معاذ وحتى لقب جيل
كامل اليوم صار تقريبا
صار تقريبا يعني انا حياه الرياضيه مع
المنتخب البلجيكي ولم يفوز باي لقب والسبب
في ذلك هو المغرب والسبب في ذلك المغرب
[ضحك]
هو المدرب البلجيكي
والبرتغالي استقال بعد الانسحاب امام
المغرب
يعني المنتخب الوطني او المركز الثالث
بالنسبه للمنتخب الوطني المغربي عن الشيء
الكثير وليس فقط غير المنتخبه
الافريقيه والمنتخبات العربيه لانه احتلال
مركز تالت على مستوى عرسي عالمي لاول مره
في تاريخ الكره القدم العالميه اعتقد انه
يعني انجازه الغيره
واعتقد على انه يعني نتيجه اكثر من مشرفه
وبالتالي ستبقى عالقه في او تبقى مكتوبه
في سجلات التاريخ على مستوى كره القدم
العالميه زيد على ذلك على ان المنتخب
الوطني المغربي والشعور
بالخروج بمرفوع الراس اكتر
باعتزاز اكثر هو الفوز على كرواتيا
واحتلال مركز الثالث امام عمالقه كره
القدم هذا الشيء اعتقد هو طموح اللاعبين
طموح المسؤولين وطموح ايضا الجمهور والامه
العربيه ككل المنتخب صحيح ان المنتخب
المغربي الان يعني ويجر وراءه اعطاه
واعياء ويعني اصابات ولكن هذا الرغم من
ذلك ستكون هناك يعني لاعبون اللاعبون
الذين سيشاركون والذين كانوا في السابق او
اللاعبون الذين سيعودون اللاعبون
المعطوبون كلهم امل وطموح ويمكن اكثر في
بلوغ هذا الطموح وفي بلوغ هذا هذه النتيجه
والرجوع الى الوطن
كاس العالم طيب مراد الان انت تحدثت على
الذين
بالتاكيد سيكون حاضرا يوم الاحد ولكن
سيكون حاضر لاعبين
من نفس الفريق باريس سان جيرمان ميسي و
مبابي اذا الكل وهما لاعبان كل منهما يريد
ان يسجل اسمه في التاريخ اكثر من ما كان
يتوقع بتسجيل اكبر عدد من الاهداف اذان
المباراه بالتاكيد لن تنتهي بسفر لصفر
من ذلك كل شيء ممكن لكن الفريق الارجنتيني
يعني على العموم فريق مبني همم على الدفاع
اولا بذات يعني لو ان الكره ما تكون في
ساقين ميسي نادرا ما همم نراه فريقا
هجوميا فرجويا مهاريا حتى انتصار وتذكر
واسع استغل تقريبا ربع ساعه من البهجه
دفاعيه الغير مسبقه لكرواسيا وتمكن من
تسجيل هدفين لا يبدولي وعنه الدفاع
الفرنسي سيكون بذلك بتلك ما يسمى همم
معناها وصف كوره
توفيق
على الاقل اكيد هو انه باريس سان جيرمان
ونادي في ملكيه القطريه له نجمين سيلعب
بين الدوري
يحلم به كل من نظم او ساهم في تنظيم كاس
العالم ولن نترك الالسنن الخبيثه الا اذا
كان انت تحب تقول ان هذا الكل كانوا مسطر
الى توفيق ولكن في الاخير يعني همم سكر
على الميدان وانه مبابي يكون ضد ميسي في
اللقاء الذي كان يحلم به الجميع ولو طبعا
كان كذلك يعني حتى على الشعبي كاس العالم
فريق مثل البرازيل في النهائي كان يعطي
لهذا لهذا الدور النهائي همم همم يعني
رونقا خاصه اتمنى ان تكون او نتمنى كلنا
ان تكون همم يكون دور نهائي تقريبا من
طينه ذلك تلك المقابله الرائعه مباراه ثمن
النهائي في دوره 2018 في روسيا من لما
فازت فرنسا على الارجنتين 4-3 وكنت تقريبا
اقوى مباراه لفرنسا في تلك في تلك الدوره
في كاس العالم والتي مهدت للانتصار ال-
همم الفرنسي انت اتحدث عن مبابي مبابي
عمره ما زال ما اغلقش 23 سنه ويلعب ثاني
دور نهائي لكاس العالم في حياته الرياضيه
هناك لاعبين ان هي وحقيقتهم الرياضيه الكل
وملعبوش همم دور نهائيا لكاس العالم واحد
بركه معناها همم
للتفكير همم فقط
حجم الانجاز الانجاز الفرنسي هذا وقيمه
الانجاز الفرنسي اكبر نجم في تاريخ الكره
الفرنسيه اللي هو ميشيل البلاتينيه ميشيل
الباتينيه عمره ما العب نهائي بتاع كاس
جون بير بافال يهز الكره الذهبيه عمره ما
العبد بتاع كاس عالم لكن اليوم عندك جيل
مش فقط كيليان بطيء طبعا لكن اصغر وابرز
لاعب انطوان جريزمان حسب رايي ثاني احسن
لاعب في كاس العالم بعد بعد ميسي همم
ضيفوه لهم همم الحارس يقول رئيس
الكل يلعب بثينه نهائي كاس عالم
مش موجود في المجموعه في 2018 نتحدث تعلم
يعني هذا ما يدلوا ان اراعه بالرغم من
احيانا اسلوب فيه وعليه بعض الدفاعي فانه
جديد شو دخل التاريخ الكره العالميه وانهي
توفيق اذا فتان اللي هو هز كاس العالم
كنعم معناها عفوا 98 لان نسينا معنى عنده
وهز وهز الشامبيونز ليج كان يلعب مع
مارسيليا ديشا اليوم همم يعني يصنع تاريخ
الكره ما عندي مقوله عشان نقول كلمه
يفهموها العرب الكل شاب
طيب مباراه ستكون صعبه
الى حد بعيد انا اقوله ربما
خبره اديشان يتغلب على
ممكن
نقارن بين الفريقين انهم فريقين
متكاملين الى حد بعيد اما متكاملا الى حد
بعيد في جميع الخطوط
خطه الارجنتين واضحه خطه الارجنتين يلعب
باربعه اربعه اربعه اثنين ويخليه ميسي
تكون الكره الارجنتين يفعل ما يشاء
اما عن خطه خطه فرنسا واضحه الى حد بعيد
يلعب بالخطه اربعه ثلاثه ثلاثه
بمثلت مثلث رعب مثلج
جريزمان
والخط الامامي كثير من الواقعيه اقول كثير
من الواقعيه في في في اتمام الهاجمات عادل
العلو يعني غريب عنده ميسي هو انه عندما
تكون الكره لديه دون ان ينظر
الى اللاعب الاخر والكره تاتي دائما يعني
غريب حتى المعلق بين ذلك يعني عندما تراه
يلعب لانه عنده وردان
هذا هذا يعني لاعب ميسي يعتقد هل انه هو
اللاعب
بمميزات خاصه
لاعب اسطوري سواء
مع فرصه الميدان او كان على مستوى الهجوم
لاعب وحيد منتخب الارجنتين ويعني في في
نسبه نجاحه في في المباراه هي نسبه النجاح
المنتخب ذلك في المباراه الاخيره امام
الكروات كان يعني نجما من النجوم وكان
ايضا الحقيقيه لمنتخب الارجنتين اعتقد على
انه الارجنتين هي كلها تدور حول ميسي همم
يعني نجاح ميسي نجاح الارجنتين فشل ميسي
فشل الارجنتين فلا يعتقد على ان المنتخب
الارجنتين قد يحقق
نتيجه ان لم يكن ميسي في كامل جاهزيته
وايضا في كامل امكانياته بالمقابل
منتخب فرنسا يعتقد عنده اكثر من نجم
ومنتخب منتخب يمكن نقوله له من
الامكانياته من الاسلحه ما يمكن ان يهزم
بها منتخب الارجنتين او اي منتخب اخر ان
يتوجه به في المباراه خاصه في المباراه
النهائيه همم السبب واضح او للامكانيات
ثانيا الخبره التي اكتسبها اول مدربه
كما قال سيد مراد حين حمل الكاس ثم ايضا
لما فاز مع منتخب فرنسا في كاس العالم
الاول ثم ايضا لما همم يعني وصل الان الى
مبارتي النهائيه الباقيه اللاعبين هم
بالتجربه التي لهم على مستوى نواديهم
وبتجربه التي حملوها ايضا على مستوى كاس
العالم السابقه والكاس العالم الحالي لحد
الان اعتقد على انه مرشح فوق العاده لي
يحمي الكاس مره اخرى ويحقق بالتالي انجازه
الغير مسبوق لكره القدم الفرنسي التي كانت
الى وقت سابق يعني في في مصافي الانديه او
المنتخبات التي يمكن نعتبرها من الدرجه
الثانيه لحد سنه 88
الا انشئ فيها مركز
الانطلاقه الاوليه لكره القدم الفرنسيه
وانتظرنا عشر سنوات الى 98 حين فازت فرنسا
بكاس العالم ثم بعدها توالت الانجازات على
مستوى كره القدم او الانديه ايضا الفرنسيه
في المباريات الاخيره للمنتخب الفرنسي
والحديث الان عن احتمال ربما لانه حتى
الان هو في التشكيله الرسميه مع انه طبعا
غادر قطر
نلعب اوباما
هذا سؤال خبير
لانه بالفعل هناك
وهذا مش منعويدك بالفعل هناك يعني
يقال في بعض الاوسط في بعض الكواليس وان
يعني خروج بنضمام بالاصابه كان خبرا سيئا
ولكن في نفس الوقت اسعد بعض اللاعبين في
صلب الفريق الفرنسي لانه العلاقات لم تكن
طيبه دائما ما بين بنزيما او مجموعه من
اللاعبين ابرزهم مثلا وليفي جيرو ونتذكر
في وقت ما الاوقات لما بين الجماع همم كان
يعني تم اقصائهم المنتخب الفرنسي بعد
القرار القضائي ضد هو كان وصف امر في
محادثه على انستغرام انه هو بمثابه
الفيراري والفيجيرو بمثابه سيارتينج طبعا
هذا نوع من التصريحات
لا تعجب صلبه مجموعه التعايش معها
انا بصراحه همم معرفتي الجديد شلون نعتبر
انه جديد شو من المدربين اللي لا يحرم
نفسه من سلاح يمكن ان يجعله يفوز بكاس
العالم قد يكون انه طاقم الطبي الفرنسي
وهذا كان قالوا سمير نصري لاعب صديق
بنظامه لاعب سابق لمارسيليا ارسنال
مانشستر سيتي قالوا انه الطاقه من الطبي
والتعقم
التكتيكي يعني طاقم الفني الفرنسي قد اخطا
بعض الشيء مع بنزمات لانه معناه بدا معه
بنسك قوي وهو ما جعله يصعب تقريبا بسرعه
في حين كان من الممكن ان تستحفظ عليه ما
يلعبش الدور الاول ويكون جاهز للربع نهائي
نصف نهائي لكن في اخر المطاف من هو
المنتصر من هو الذي نجح الان بالوصول الى
ايه بغض النظر عن نتيجه حققه
النتيجه التي جاء من اجلها ويا الوصول دوج
بنزيما هل عنده شعبيه كبيره صلب الفريق
لست لست متاكدا يا توفيق والدليل كذلك
واختم انه بنزيما مبعث رساله على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي وتعرفا وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي صارت مهمه جدا
يعني
مؤشر لا اقول وان دليل مؤشر يعني في
الختام لمحمد بن راشمه ومدرب ومحلل ريادي
شكرا الفلوس
[موسيقى]